i'm talking about an insect called a
cicada they're in the news at the moment
in america um they are a small flying
insect and the reason they're in the
news at the moment is because they spend
a huge amount of their lives underground
and
very occasionally they come out in a big
swarm uh for the three f's feeding
fighting and mating
and um in america this particular cicada
is called a periodical cicada and this
one comes out every 17 years the reason
i want to talk about it is because it
illustrates an interesting way that
nature does
maths
because if you want to do math if you
want to solve a problem in mathematics
what you do is you start with all the
facts that you already know
you combine those facts together using
mathematical logic to create some new
fact
that you didn't know before so that's
how you would prove something in
mathematics how you would solve a
problem
this is not what they look like but
let's have a go
okay so
it's kind of uh imagine you've got a
lovely wing
there guys it's mostly wing
and big boggly red eyes maybe there's
some antenna kind of going on legs
coming out something like that
is that that's really serious yeah
that's it i mean it's look it's as close
as we're gonna get i know it looks like
a kind of a weird cow or something this
illustrates the way that nature does
maths it's basically uh instead of
having this logical methodical process
uh you just sort of have a guess
and
you see if if your answer's correct you
test it and if it's not correct then you
try a new answer and see if that gets
you any closer
and you keep trying and trying and
trying so it's a process of trial and
error and this is genuinely a way that
you can solve problems in mathematics i
think that the best example of trial and
error that the world has ever seen is
evolution so natural selection so how
has this happened with with the the
cicada um well the first thing to know
about the cicada is that it has a really
interesting method of uh protecting
itself against predators and and that is
something called predator satiation
which is basically uh where you make
yourself so numerous
that your predator is is literally full
twofold can't eat any more um and that's
how you survive but you sort of think
well how can that work surely if you uh
if you satiate your predator then your
predator is just going to come back
stronger in the next generation and and
eat even more of you
that can only work for the predator if
the predator can make its life cycle the
same as yours so it's in step with you
so it's eating when you're when you're
out and about doing your thing as well
and so the next thing that cicada does
is to make its life cycle really really
long
too long for the predator for some
reason predators can't have this really
long life cycle so that's why the cicada
has this really long life cycle
um it's to kind of get out of step with
the predator um so let's let's look at
that on the number line one two three
four fifteen sixteen
seventeen so um let's write those out so
uh zero uh one two three four
fifteen
sixteen
uh seventy so this particular circle
that's in the news comes out every 17
years there's another one that comes out
every 13 years is that important could
it be some other thing um so for example
what if the cicada chose a 12-year life
cycle the predator that's too long for
the predator he can't wait 12 years but
the predator still has a trick
so maybe the predator has a six year
life cycle instead so the predator comes
out after six years
there's a predator comes out there and
there are no cicadas but the next
generation of the predator
that's at 12 years and suddenly
there are loads of cicadas there and so
every other generation of this predator
is able to feed on cicadas and that
gives them advantage and they will grow
and they will flourish or if six years
is too long how about a four year cycle
so we go four years
no cicadas eight years no cicadas 12
years cicadas if forced too long you
could even have a three-year life cycle
so uh the first three years uh no
cicadas uh the second three years no
scholars third three years no cicadas
fourth lot of three years that's 12
years cicadas even two years that'll
work as well
so if you're a cicada and you choose a
12-year life cycle that's a terrible
decision because 12
has all these things that you can divide
it into so 12 is divided by 6 divisible
by 4 divisible by 3 divisible by 2.
so if you're a cicada you need to choose
a life cycle which just is not divisible
by anything so brady what uh what's a
number that's not divisible by anything
i'm i'm no expert i reckon you're
heading here towards prime numbers prime
numbers exactly so that is why the
cicada has chosen a 13-year life cycle
and a 17-year life cycle it's the
solution to a mathematical problem and
it's the discovery of prime numbers by
natural selection absolutely amazing
yeah so cicada lives for 17 years but uh
16 of those years are spent underground
uh as in a sort of larval state and then
they come out in a big swarm in the 17th
year 13 and 17 years seems like a long
time there are a lot of prime numbers
lower than that well yes there are um
but i suppose the issue with smaller
numbers is that
just maybe the predator could stretch to
having a life cycle that long and so
they can they can get into step with it
the great thing is by the way if you've
got a say a 13-year life cycle and your
predator has a four a four-year life
cycle and how often will the predator
and the prey meet well it's four uh
times thirteen or four times seventeen
so you have to multiply the two numbers
together and it becomes this enormous
theme and and that's that's the genius
if there was some common factor to these
two uh then then you wouldn't have to
multiply them together to find out when
they meet it be a much smaller number
the predator is a wasp it's called the
cicada killing wasp uh i don't know
where they got that name from but
uh those guys are crazy yeah the wasp is
great uh it basically uh it kills the
cicada with a sting and then it
plants an egg
inside the cicada's dead body which then
feeds on it from the inside
and then releases a a wasp at the end of
it it's a great way to go
but yeah i love that i love the idea of
satiating your predator like you you
really don't want to be in the vanguard
of
you know of this regard a group
when that's your when that's your policy
you have to go really far down this
approximation
root before you get close to the golden
ratio much more so than pi or whatever
so the golden ratio is the most
irrational number